[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
hello there tonight Piers Morgan
uncensored with me of course Rosanna
Lockwood after weeks of speculation
Buckingham Palace confirms Prince Harry
will come to the king's coronation but
without Megan the event falls on the
same day as their son Archie's fourth
birthday is it an unfortunate
coincidence or the latest Royal snub
from the California living couple
Joe Biden hails 25 years of Peace in
Northern Ireland but hostility around
his Belfast visit remains as he's
accused of hating the UK officials for
the president insist he's not
anti-british but where exactly do we
stand in the special relationship
and after around a 120 leading lawyers
vowed not to prosecute what they call
peaceful climate protesters we ask
whether the move undermines the basics
of the justice system
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored with Rosanna Lockwood
hello there good evening welcome to
Piers morganland center with me Rosanna
in for today tomorrow appears still on
holiday now it's confirmed after weeks
will they won't they Prince Harry and
Megan have gained to return their RSVP
for the king's coronation next month but
guess what only Harry is coming Megan is
staying behind in California with the
kids and the palace said they're pleased
to confirm Harry's attendance sources
close to the sussexes meanwhile saying
Prince Archie's fourth birthday which is
actually on the same day as the
coronation was a big factor in the
couple's decision but a child's fourth
birthday party really seems a little bit
like a convenient excuse for a more
personal decision for Megan to stay home
in Montecito and for once this probably
actually pleases both her critics and
her supporters it means she's staying
out of the line like well Harry gets to
come home even if it is only for a few
hours now it's something I've been
thinking about today amid these
accusations that President Biden quote
hates the UK we'll go into that a bit
later on
um how do we deal with the idea that
someone might be anti-british when a
figure we trust appears to abandon a
love for Britain I think it's not so
much about them as it is about us my
hunch is Harry has never been and will
never be anti-british he loves this
country but in this Rebellion over the
past few years his words and his actions
they've hurt us and the fact he's coming
back next month to be part of this
historic moment shows he does want to be
here but will we welcome him that very
much depends on us while joining me to
discuss all this broadcaster and
playwright Bonnie Greer lovely see you
again Bonnie and former press secretary
to the queen Dickie Arbiter thank you
both joining us down the line as well
former BBC Royal correspondent Jenny
Bond Jenny we were wondering whether you
complete the royal blue set this evening
but looking resplendent
resplendent in Tartan and Jenny given
you're joining us from home this evening
let's just start with you and ask were
you at all surprised by the decision the
announcement this afternoon
no I thought it was always going to turn
out this way and I think it's the best
solution actually uh Megan unfortunately
is a person who divides opinion I I she
probably doesn't wish to but she does
divide opinion and I think she was over
here then there would be a huge debate
about whether she was welcome or not she
might her presence would possibly
overshadow the coronation but it's
always been important that Harry should
be here be here for the biggest day in
his father's life really uh Charles has
made it clear that he still loves his
son whatever's going on that he wants
him to be there and so I'm very pleased
that Harry is coming and I think it's a
much better solution that Megan should
stay back in California with the
children quite reasonable Dickie coming
to you your knowledge of the protocol of
course the Royal household the palace uh
the late Queen it is the right decision
surely for Harry to attend this event
it's very much the right decision given
everything that's gone before the Oprah
interview the six hours of Netflix the
book uh and all the little bits of
interviews in between uh people
wonderful well how can you show his face
at the coronation but it is the right
decision his father loves him as Jenny
rightly said we heard in his uh his
first address following the death of his
mother where he sent his love to both
Harry and Megan in California so it is
the right decision what I do hope is
that it's not a distraction because what
will happen is the media will focus
their attention on him the photographers
will focus attention they'll haul out
out of the woodwork all the body
language experts and we'll get all sorts
of things I want to see us focusing on a
once in a lifetime for me it's the
second time because I saw the Queen's
coronation but I I want to see the focus
of attention on the king it's his day
and it's the the people of Britain's day
as well and certainly it seems to a big
distraction like you said anything about
Harry of course people be watching what
his relationship will be like with
William on the day as well perhaps we'll
come back to Junior that first want to
come to you Bonnie on Megan's decision
to stay behind in in Montecito with the
children
um I think there was no other way
shortly no that's absolutely right she
made her mother's decision she's still
got little children that is her son's
birthday uh she made the right decision
and I have to say I'm actually quite
moved in a way that Harry's decided to
do this it's very grown up it's very
proper uh it's a tribute to his Gran who
he loved and his father but most of all
his children and I'm putting my
historians hat on his children are
probably two of the most extraordinary
people ever born because on one side his
side they're descended from every Royal
head they that ever was including the
prophet and on their mother's side
through her mother they are descended
from my ancestors not my literal
ancestors but this but uh enslaved
Africans so you have this lovely
combination and one day Harry's going to
sit these kids down and say this is your
heritage too the other part that you
because these could be American kids
they're going to be brought up as
Americans they ain't going to be called
Prince Archie and Princess Lily but in
the United States I'm gonna tell you
that but nevertheless they they will see
this other side and it it they're going
to be extraordinary individuals because
of that so I'm happy he's there because
he can say dad there's Dad I was there
shouldn't they be there then Lily
they're too little and I wouldn't I mean
I wouldn't bring them they are they are
far too young what do you think of the
king that he was at his mother's
coronation probably for about half an
hour
he was three years old no the children
should not be there this is not a
children's circus this is a very devout
service
it is a coronation it is anointing in
the eyes of God the king and therefore
know the children should not be there
they've got the right kids there uh
George playing a role and the other
children playing a role but no Archie
and Lily shouldn't be there and George
should be there he is the third line
sorry he is he is now let's get back to
Jenny on the distraction uh Point Jenny
uh the Dickie brought up surely the
presence of Harry in and of himself is
just going to be something of a media
circus is there any way around it
oh it will be it would have been more of
a media circus had Megan been here as
well but you know we've only got
ourselves to blame to this and I've said
for some months now that um if Harry and
Megan came or even just Harry coming
what we should do we the media should
say also in attendance was the Duke of
Sussex we don't need to go wild about it
we don't need to bring in the body
language Experts of course we will of
course we will that's what we do but
we've earn ourselves to blame um but I I
agree and concur with uh Dicky that this
is Charles's day
um and that's where the focus should be
and I'm very sorry that in the leader to
the decision that's been and finally
announced today
um there's been so much attention on um
Harry and Megan I mean I think it is
rude that they've taken so long to
answer a very simple question you're
invited to this occasion are you coming
and they've kept us all of them came to
hooks for weeks and weeks but but Jenny
we were kept on tender hooks because we
wanted to be on them okay we didn't have
to pay so much attention to them people
do and it's not necessary I agree with
you about and Dicky this is the King's
day and this is the King's day as long
as we allow it to be the King's day and
I think that when Harry comes I think he
will contribute to it being the King's
day and not only that his dad's day and
I'm very proud of him I think it's a
very mature decision and it's not like
to qualify what Bolly just said she said
uh um we made a decision we the media
make the decision that it is focus of
attention on the king and on the queen
consort and not on everybody else that
is there yes certain people do have
roles to play and they will be seen
visually uh Port during that role but
the congregation of which Harry is a
part of does not play a part in the in
the correlation ceremony and therefore
we in the media must Focus attention on
the big picture so this is your campaign
Dicky this evening to try and get the
media to listen but it won't happen yeah
it won't happen because there's all
kinds Dickie knows and Jenny knows
there's not just the media the print
media there is social media there's all
kinds of things happening they've been
happening for two weeks on social media
so Harry coming I think and where he
will be positioned and his and his uh uh
response to God Save the King and all of
that is going to be a deep focus but he
has to be there and I like I say I'm
proud that he's decided to come as part
of the fabric of History it does seem
imperatively Dicky you were nodding
along vigorously when Jenny was saying
it was very rude of Harry Megan to hold
up
didn't take them a month to reply they
either he or she or they knew that they
were coming or they didn't Harry knew he
definitely had to be there and he sort
of responded immediately without waiting
a month without all this speculation
that's gone on for over 30 days but
Dicky we were speculating I mean who
knows why it took them that long I don't
know but we were speculating I'm saying
not you personally no I wasn't I mean
it's it's the public that's speculating
and the and the the more that we take
ourselves away from these two
individuals as individuals let this
ceremony happen I know it won't be like
that but just let the ceremony happen it
is Charles's day he's been waiting for
what 67 years for it so let's just let
him have his day bringing Jenny back in
on this because it is as uh Dickey and
Bonnie have been pointing out it's it's
Charles's dates the Kings days also the
country's day there's going to be Street
parties it should be a very jubilant
Affair however this Harry visit of
course will be part of the circus as
we've already discussed
um
do you think that they can get past it
how do you think the royal family are
going to deal with this how do you think
they're going to instill this sense of
decorum
well it'll all go perfectly wonderfully
these vacations always do
um they would be polite and courteous to
one another William by definition has
got a very important role to play uh
during the coronation ceremony and
therefore I think he will be physically
apart from Harry so we won't be able to
analyze their every look that every
movement uh the two will be separated
um and there's no reason for them to to
meet at all because I think Harry's
going to fly straight in and straight
out as he did quite recently through a
court case apparently without seeing
anyone uh so there may be no meeting
between the two brothers and the
animosity between two the two obviously
is still very very deep
um so I think it will all go as smoothly
as these Royal occasions do go and we
will all try to draw some kind of
conclusions
um about how they're looking at each
other but none of it will be realistic I
don't think
um I think the tensions are so deep and
the Rifts so hurt for at the moment that
is going to take more than a flying
visit by by Harry to put things right
um just before we wrap up I want to ask
you both briefly do you think the
British public is going to be welcoming
to Harry Dickey the British public going
to be welcoming for the coronation it's
the King's day and they're going to
focus on the Kings Day and everybody
else is just there Harry is going to
find it very difficult he's going to
feel very lonely because he's fallen out
with his family he is there as a matter
of Duty but he's got no support his
wife's thousands of miles away in
California and he's going to hack this
one alone yeah well someone privileged
to be a British citizen for a long time
now and watching funerals and weddings
the British people will stand right up
to this it'll be beautiful they'll let
it all smooth out and here he will go
home back to Montecito it'll be fine
we'll be talking much more about
anti-britishness and the idea of being
British after the break thanks so much
to our panel on the Royal story this
evening next tonight Joe Biden orishi
sunak insists that the relationship
between the UK and the US is in great
shape despite strong criticism of the
president and accusations he's
anti-british will be discussing after
the break
[Music]
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage and you're
stretching it you can say whatever
gender you are but your sex your male or
your female all right JJ plus he becomes
fabulous but Rishi tsuna he sets out
this five-point plan what has it
achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
laughs
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show now what does
it mean to be anti-british that's what
U.S President Biden has been accused of
in the past 24 hours on a visit to
Northern Ireland now it hasn't helped
that there were some disappointing
photos from this coffee meeting with
British PM Rishi sooner this morning
look at this plus a video where Biden
appeared to move the British prime
minister out the way to salute a guard
last night now today a White House
official actually had to dispel this
anti-british accusation
it's it's simply uh untrue why the fact
that that the the the president is going
to be engaging for the third time in
three months and then again next month
and then again in in June uh with the
prime minister of the UK shows how close
our our cooperation is with the the UK
uh and before that the president had
numerous calls and and meetings with
with prime minister Johnson uh and and
prime minister trust as well now to some
that response wasn't enough and it
doesn't actually help that Biden has
turned down an invite to the king's
coronation next month so what's
happening is you're just not a fan of us
Brits joining me now to discuss all of
this of course it's more complex than
that former dup politician Jim Wells and
finagale Irish minister of State Neil
Richmond thank you gentlemen both for
joining us
um gonna start this off very simply Jim
I'll come to you first is by Nancy
British
well if it's not it is
it shows I'm very disappointed that he's
not going through the coronation and
it's traditional for all American
presidents to attend that important
state event I have no idea why he
couldn't find the time
I think part of the problem is he's
simply here to
um keep the irish-american vote back in
the States
um on his side very powerful political
Lobby and I I think that's the reason
he's here not of any interest in in
fostering relationships with Britain or
or indeed with unionism just to try and
keep that big block on board so yeah
we've been disappointing to put it
mildly uh and I think he's not the
anglo-american relations back again for
years just just put it pushing you back
a little bit on that argument there uh
Jim because I hear the the Irish
American vote is what he's garnering but
is it really all that powerful is it
worth potentially losing friends in
Britain as the accusations were made
today in order to get that re-election
chance in 2024 with Irish Americans
it is if you're a Democrat because all
the history has shown that the
overwhelming majority of those who
identify as Irish be at fourth fifth
generation detached are Democrat
supporters so therefore as Obama did
when he came over to uh Ireland um eight
years ago it is very much focused on the
Home Market rather than anything that's
going on in the UK I still think he
should have found time to come to the
coronation I think that's a retrograde
step but he actually only visited
Northern Ireland for for less than 20
hours he came in stayed overnight opened
the new University of Ulster and then
went straight to the Irish Republic
hardly indicates to these particularly
serious about Northern Ireland compared
to say Bill Clinton who spent day after
day here so um leading visit to put it
made the once you see him now you don't
I mean it was about 15 hours somebody
said half of that he was sleeping but it
sounds quite like a lot of official
visits you hear from world leaders Neil
coming to you now with that same very
basic question is by 90 British
absolutely not and I think it's a
ridiculous and to be honest very
precious uh charge you know at the end
of the day the U.S British relationship
is as strong now as it's ever been this
will be six um you know over the next
six months or C6 uh discussions between
the president and the British prime
minister we see the US and the UK
working so closely together in terms of
supporting Ukraine and the economic
relationship is absolutely flourishing
but one thing I think is really
important why Joe Biden is here is to
celebrate not just mark But celebrate 25
years since the Good Friday agreement
was signed and ultimately the big
disappointment is he spent so little
time in Northern Ireland because there
was no Northern Irish government for
into Mason that's something that Jim's
former colleagues in the dup have to
answer for why wasn't there first
Minister a deputy first Minister we have
a president of the United States are
going back to his time in the Senators
as chair of the Foreign Relations
Committee has shown a genuine interest
in knowledge in life across this island
I think it was really interesting if you
actually listened to the president's
speech in University Ulster today he
spoke very warned me about his Heritage
not just his Heritage his family and
County life and County Mayo but the fact
that his family had British Origins but
also just like myself as Barry prayed I
was Ulster Scots Origins so I think the
notion that all of a sudden Joe Biden is
anti-british about the special
relationship with the cards I think it's
absolutely farcical and the person who
made us was probably just trying to sell
a few newspapers let's listen to Joe
Biden give me that address today
as a friend I hope it's not too
presumptuous for me to say that I
believe Democratic institutions
established to the Good Friday agreement
remain critical to the future of
Northern Ireland it's a decision of you
to make not for me to make
but it seems to me they're related
an effective devolved government that
reflects the people of Northern Ireland
and is accountable to them
now kicking the Diplomatic can somewhat
into the long grass some might say quite
responsibly there should the U.S have
any role to play in this but others
saying that Biden's input today into
talking about the power sharing
agreement that exists in Northern
Ireland any type of political uh Dynamic
was a little bit weak um Jim I want to
give you a chance to respond to uh
Neil's comments about some of your
former colleagues in the dup
well I mean there's a much bigger issue
than President Biden's visit and that's
the protocol and winter framework you
need to see that as a fundamental threat
to their very existence within the
United Kingdom this year's becoming a
semi-detached colony of the European
Union uh a few miles from the rest of
the UK and that is much more important
than a presidential visit or indeed any
other issue at the minute facing the
Northern Ireland electorate and the
unionism is basically made the point
that they will not participate in
executive provided that sort of damage
cases hanging with their neck that
constitutional Rift that we Face we
still remain within the single Market
which Still Remains subject to the
European court of justice we still have
the European bat regime none of that's
acceptable to unionism and that is why
we're using the leverage we have to
remaining outside the executive uh to
try and Achieve change in the protocol
and frankly though Joe Biden did go out
of his way today to urge the dup to go
back in it's going to take an awful lot
more than that before we can change
because senior selected are with us on
this issue look uh as you said
urging him to go back in but um Neil
coming to you one dupmp saying Biden
should have come up with some creative
ideas to help this political Dynamic do
you think that's fair do you think Biden
should have that responsibility
you know I think anyone in the dup is
going to start lecturing people about
creative ideas to solve the problem that
is brexit the problem that they campaign
for themselves is a bit Rich the dup
held the balance of power on Westminster
for two years the dup throughout this
seven year period has said no to
everything they've brought into being
brought into the conversation the
concerns have been listened to and
whilst Jim feels he represents all of
the unionism we see the responsible
comments by the leader of the Austria
unionist party that within the Windsor
framework something that's been backed
massively by the British Parliament
there is the opportunity to close this
chapter of the brexit discussions to
give the people of Northern Ireland like
prime minister sunak has said himself
the opportunities to have brilliant
economic ties of both the United Kingdom
and indeed the European Union and this
very notion that there's a
constitutional Rift has been absolutely
struck down by the UK Supreme Court now
I'm no unionist online I'm not from
Northern Ireland the United Kingdom but
I think I'd listen to Westminster my
Westminster Parliament and indeed the
Supreme Court of the UK if I was one and
Neil a sub colony of the European Union
yeah a complete notion and it's this
it's complete ridiculous notion of this
sort of extreme language that we've seen
consistently from people who aren't
prepared to do the hard work we talk
about the very vague seven tests of the
dup but at no stage are they actually
preferred any real solutions that
problems uh brexit calls we have uh very
hard brexit due to decision of the
British government but we respect that
in the European Union we absolutely
respect it but also we respect the
absolute importance to ensure there's no
hardening of the border on this island
what we have is a very minimal amount of
certain Goods coming into four ports
eventually of Northern Ireland checks
that can be reduced further with further
negotiation discussion and indeed
Northern Ireland can have a break on in
terms of their discussions we have the
opportunity to move on this but I would
question whether or not there's certain
people politically who do don't want to
move on to this in transgens and who
don't realize that by getting the
executive back up and running getting
the assembly back up and running not
only will the people of Northern Ireland
benefit politically and socially but we
will unleash massive amounts of U.S
investment into the whole of the island
bearing complaint that U.S companies
employ over 10 percent of the workplace
in the public like that Northern Ireland
too Neil I hear what you're saying I
want to bring in another character on
this because of course Britain uh
absolutely integral to brexit um and
post-brexit Trade Agreement negotiations
those images today have sooner combined
meeting for their bilarte their coffee
meeting and also soon accidentally sort
of pushed aside some might say bye Biden
on the tarmac last night Jim I want to
come to you and ask does uh does CNAC
have the confidence of Northern Ireland
as long as he's wedded to the Windsor
framework most definitely he he doesn't
and there is a solution to all of this
it's called the protocol bill which is
still before Parliament we've always
said that that bill which is initiated
by Richie sunick's party goes a long
long way to meeting unionist concerns
about the protocols so it's wrong to say
with an entirely negative we've
supported that bill and we also
supported voluntary Coalition in
Northern Ireland rather than the present
forced marriage between parties a very
disparate uh political outlooks so so
the dup have been positive but the
question I asked my colleague from the
doyle is um was he a specifics against
Shinn Fein when they boycotted the
assembly for three years over a very
minor issue called the Irish language
Act was he as critical as them as he's
being of the dup
Neil actually I was doing consistently
and I'd been a master critic of
champagne both in terms of the politics
here in this jurisdiction as well as
Northern Ireland and I'm quite on the
record that their decision to pull down
a stormt over the Ashford Scandal and
indeed the Irish language Act was a
mistake and I criticized them but
ultimately you have a situation now
where the dup had decided to Target my
party's leader Leo varadkar incorrectly
and you talk about the positivity of the
protocol Bill all the protocol bill
would do would break international law
and setback relations between the UK and
the UK the EU the UK and Ireland and the
UK and the us back decades where instead
if we actually had the institutions back
up and running around have the
politicians in Northern Ireland take
their rightful place in the assembly in
the executive get the north side
material Council back up and running we
can actually work through issues rather
than hectoring each other from newspaper
articles or indeed online syndicated
programs Jim Wells Neil Richmond you've
both given us a very good representation
of just how complex the political
Dynamic is in Northern Ireland at the
moment we've got you on to talk about
Biden and anti-britishness you've both
responded in the negative to that we
appreciate your inputs thanks so much
coming up next after lawyers across the
UK sign a declaration saying Dell
refused to prosecute peaceful climate
protesters we asked what exactly is a
peaceful protest and does this all make
a mockery of the legal justice system
join us in a few minutes for that
foreign
[Music]
he sets out this five-point plan what
has it achieved so far nothing when we
say believe women take them at their
word I'm sick of apology
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
foreign
politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to First Morgan uncensive
me Rosanna Lockwood sitting in the big
chair for the big man this evening now
more than 120 lawyers have banded
together in England to refuse to
prosecute climate protesters such as
just stop oil insulate Britain and
Extinction Rebellion whose tactics
include gluing themselves to roads to
stop traffic now the group's lawyers are
responsible is made up of Barrister
solicitors and academics but the
Declaration breaks their professional
code of conduct which means that they
have to keep personal politics out of
their job well this is going to be a
fascinating discussion isn't it joining
me in the studio Harry Wilkinson head of
policy at Net Zero watch activist Danica
McCarthy and Paul powsland a Lloyd
refusing to prosecute climate protesters
Paul um let's start with using as you're
part of this group this one to do just
lay out to us uh what it is you're
hoping to achieve and what you all
agreed well there's actually two parts
to it so the first is the one that's
taken I think more of the headlines
which is the non-prosecution of peaceful
climate activists and the second is um
not helping to facilitate new fossil
fuel expansion projects and actually
that's actually more relevant to me
because I'm a civil law Barrister so I
actually don't do criminal prosecution
so that second one is is more my thing
so that I understand so for example a
shell or BP asks you to act on their
behalf in in a court case you'd say
sorry no I'm not going to do that based
on being part of this group based on
ethics no no it's not necessarily about
representing them at all so for instance
if um the head of an oil company was on
criminal prosecution for a corporate
manslaughter or something then we would
represent them it's very specifically
not assisting them with new fossil fuel
expansion projects because we know what
the consequences of those projects will
be because the ipcc has told us and so
it's the subtle distinction between
subtle but important distinction between
um not will represent people who are
accused of a crime but we won't help
them to continue committing that crime
and that's a really important
distinction and give us a sense of why
this contravenes your rules as a
barrister because isn't it the case that
you're not allowed to let sort of Ethics
well ethics is obviously important to a
job but personal politics interfere with
people's right to defense yeah I should
just say that the bar Standards Board
hasn't actually told me if it is is or
isn't allowed yet I've written a letter
saying I think it's actually probably
okay because I haven't actually
um refused any instructions yet um but
it may be in breach we're not quite sure
yet
um but it does I think it's fair to say
that it does contravene a principle that
lawyers hold highly which is that we
should represent anyone but we think
firstly that the climate crisis is so
serious that these two principles need
to be upheld
um and also that we need to re-weight
the scales a bit the fact is is that um
lawyers acting the fossil fuel companies
have helped facilitate 1.6 trillion
worth of new fossil fuel projects since
2017 since the Paris agreement and how
much have they those lawyers acted for
climate protests or those trying to stop
the climate crisis very very few so what
this declaration does is just help to to
tip the scales back a little bit
good context I want to come back to you
to find out how that's working in
practice and also I think the bar
association is going to find out this
evening that you're on television
talking about it I've I I've written a
letter telling them what I've done so
they're fully aware donica and Harry I
want to come to you uh both because
Harry you're you're with a head of
policy at Net Zero watch
um now this organization talks a lot
about Net Zero and kind of I think it's
fair to say sort of campaigns against
the concept of Net Zero when you listen
to Paul describe why he doesn't want to
act for uh people that expand fossil
fuels can't you understand that argument
I think this is incredibly irresponsible
because lawyers are there to underpin
the legal system what are we fighting to
save if you are a climate activist
hopefully a flourishing society and
we're very fortunate in this country to
actually benefit from trust in the rule
of law and anyone who can find
themselves in a court of law should be
able to expect that the court system is
going to treat them without any
suggestion that personal political views
uh will come into this so while I
appreciate there are some qualifications
here I think it sends out the wrong
message that actually that the law
depends on people's personal uh
political views when actually you know
this is about judging whether people
have breached the law that is a matter
um for barristers to debate
um and and that's what they should stick
to Donna Carl come to you on the climate
activist shortly but Paul irresponsible
of you uh no and I think that's a
slightly naive view of the way the legal
system and justice system works as I
said before what we're actually seeing
is not that we're all equal before the
courts the fact is is that almost all of
your viewers out there do not have the
money that would allow them to employ
these lawyers at the fossil fuel
companies are using and let's be clear
the fossil fuel industry is one of the
richest industries that has ever existed
of course they're going to use their
wealth to try and get lawyers to act in
their interests and that's what that's
what this what that's leading to is a
situation where they are actually
getting
um things weighted unfairly in their
favor and similarly with prosecution
it's not as simple as saying oh you've
broken the law everyone gets prosecuted
equally they do not for instance I live
on a river where the water company is
throwing sewage into the river illegally
completely illegally they admit it a
serious crime they've never been
prosecuted because there is
prosecutorial discretion and that at the
moment is being used much more against
climate activists people are being
prosecuted for climate activism it
simply wouldn't be prosecuted otherwise
let's speak about the climate Act of
astonica coming to you because I know
that you have your own activism and you
also speak out on behalf of climate
activists now a lot of our viewers find
it hard to find sympathy with just stop
oil and with Extinction Rebellion I
think you've probably seen some of the
broadcasts from this network before on
this and the arguments that do ensue
because was it's felt like the violence
sometimes the violent non-peaceful
protests lose the cause lose people on
the the important topic the No Doubt
important topic of climate change so is
it not right that people who cause
violent disruptions
keep using the word violent it to me
Extinction Rebellion that's a smear and
that's a smear on a thousands of
peaceful activists please don't do that
that's not that's not a good way to
approach this debate I I that is because
we're talking about what is peaceful and
what is not if we want to talk about
violence
Extinction Rebellion has not injured a
single person
your company the old companies are the
33 million people were flooded in their
homes in Pakistan that's violence there
are 30 million people starving in in the
Sahel that's violence so when we're
talking about the law we need to go back
to Nuremberg because what Nuremberg said
if if the lawyers and the judges are
involved in in perpetrating a great evil
then they then it is wrong for them to
collude with the law and I believe what
these lawyers are doing I'm doing that
now because this to us is a greater evil
than what was perpetrated in the second
world war the World Bank said that
climate crisis is greater than World War
One World War II and the Great Recession
put together so the law at the moment
defends the climate companies and the
think tanks and the prosecutes us that's
upside down and that needs to be
reversed I appreciate you contending me
on the word violence I'm going to
contend you on likening apples and
oranges climate change and uh the
prosecution of climate change activists
of the Nuremberg trials I think equating
human directed genocide with the climate
change agenda and what is happening in
climate change which I believe in very
much so science-based climate change I
think that is again a very unhelpful
comparison you know what the word
existential means of course well the
word essential I think sounds cuddly but
when the UN Secretary General says
Humanity's facing an existential crisis
he is saying the future of humanity at
stake and what's happening at the moment
is the lower backs those who are
threatening our existence the old
companies and the think tanks and it
actually prosecutes us and you talk
about fairness in the law when I'm in
court I can't afford a lawyer
when when activists are in court at the
moment the the judge is telling the
actors we are not allowed to tell the
jury why we're there why we are putting
our freedom on the line to actually save
humanity and that's why there needs to
be a red rebalancing and I think your
voice is of climate activists do need to
be heard but I'm here Harry you've got
to make here on
you're being prosecuted Danica because
you're breaking the law we have laws in
this country we have to respect and
let's be real here they are putting
lives at risk ambulances haven't been
able to reach hospitals because of
activists who have been blocking the
road that's a daily man and there's been
a number of cases this is seriously
impacting
um on the emergency services and let's
remember it isn't a cynical fossil fuel
companies that just want to burn fossil
fuels for the sake of it fossil fuels
underpin so many of our of how we do
things in the modern world we wouldn't
be able to keep our hospitals powered
without fossil fuels we wouldn't be able
to get to work I do understand that we
do need energy we're very reliant on it
but do you do you believe in climate
change absolutely absolutely so how
would you like to see activism directed
towards making people more aware of it I
think sensible Solutions like nuclear
energy and and solutions that keep
energy affordable because actually if
Energy prices run eyes as we've seen
over the course of the energy crisis
people will be thinking you know this
isn't going to improve my living
standards and actually you know it's
it's
um it's cheap Technologies
we are agreed that actually we shouldn't
be choosing expensive forms of of energy
the cheapest form of energy at the
moment is onshore wind and we're the
only country in the world that's banned
it it's not extraordinary and this
organization lobbied in 2013 to actually
stop the installation program Lord
Lawson a part of his organization
lobbied and that meant that nine million
homes
didn't have their homes insulated and
they paid the price this winter with not
only with fuel property but a lot of
them are with their lives because nine
to eight thousand people die in Britain
every year because their homes are not
insulated so I want this organization
when we talk about the law and he says
we must obey the law but the low backs
him and not earth exactly let's let's
hear from the law let's round off
the law but
what I'm hearing from both of these
gentlemen Danica and Harry is that we
want to see leadership coming from
elsewhere in society other than just
activists you want to see companies
government everyone else leading so
having a band of lawyers doing this do
you think you can make a difference I
think it already has I think it's
inspired many of the lawyers around the
world so other lawyers of contact are
saying people in the UK are doing this
we can do this too and also other
activists when they see lawyers standing
up and actually uh doing something on
principle on conscience I think that has
a real power to it and also say just in
response to tahari's point about yes of
course we need fossil fuels at the
moment but we need to begin the
transition as soon as possible which is
why our declaration doesn't say we will
never act for a fossil fuel company it
very specifically States we will not
help them to do fossil fuel expansion
because we know from the ipcc what the
consequences of that will be so we we
can have fossil fuels now for the
transition but we need to start very
quickly in that transition and fossil
fuel companies are deliberately
obscuring and blocking that transition
because it's in their monetary and just
to do so and they're using lawyers to do
that don't see more oil and gas
extraction and fund it then we will see
prices rise
Rises
one argument Harry's prices and cost of
living and we are all feeling it the
other is uh the future of the planet and
the future of our existence let
gentlemen it's been fascinating learned
a lot this evening great to have you uh
debating this with us and teaching us
about what lawyers are doing in all of
this now next tonight is work culture to
blame for high taxes former prime
minister let's trust certainly seems to
think so I'll be diving into that next
thank you
[Music]
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage and you're
stretching it you can say whatever
gender you are for your sex your male or
your female all right JJ plus he becomes
fabulous but Richard sets out this
five-point plan what has it achieved so
far nothing when we say believe women
take them at their word I'm sick of
apology
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
and coming up on the talk Meghan Markle
will miss the king's coronation as the
sussexes finally send off that RSVP with
Prince Harry attending alone and
speaking of snubs the White House
defends President Biden who's been
branded anti-british during his visit to
Northern Ireland and can men be Divas
will be discussing all of that and much
more at night
thank you
welcome back to the show joining me now
to share this on the stories of the day
associate editor at the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire talktv contributor Esther
Krakow joining us both now there's a lot
to discuss I wanted to start here Liz
truss speaking in the US she's been
speaking at this Think Tank event today
it's supposed to be her grand comeback
let's take a listen
a new kind of economic model taking hold
in our countries one that's focused on
redistributionism
on stagnation
and on the IM viewing of woke culture
into our businesses
I call these people the anti-growth
movement and they come in many shapes
and sizes now apart from equating
wokeness to taxes which I'll come to you
both on this was the line that stood out
to me from this comeback supposedly for
but let's trust she said last autism
quote I had a major setback but I care
too much to give up I'm sorry I'm sorry
I care you can give up the hubris of
that yeah you kind of expect men and
women in white courts flapping white
chords to go on stage and take her away
oh look honestly she can go abroad to a
very very right-wing Think Tank which
will make her look like a liberal
Democrats make it look like a liberal
Democrat and she can present herself as
a prophet but everybody in Britain just
laughs at her because they know what she
did when she crashed the economy and uh
it's utterly Shameless and it's totally
absurd I hate this woman
to like why did anyone think was a good
idea to Payless jobs to give a speech
about it it's the Heritage Foundation
which is uh yeah as Kevin pointed out a
right wing Think Tank uh they've got
offices in DC they were very proud to
get Liz truss over there to launch this
comeback
keep up there we are that's sorted and
also I know trust wanted to get heard
from in the last 24 hours or so she
loves foreign policy remember of course
she was foreign secretary as well now
she's been opining about our
relationship with China and our
relationship with Russia in the last and
what we're doing in Ukraine within this
speech as well she just can't seem to
help us off I mean she's lost all
credibility that's that's the main issue
she's lost all credibility she clearly
doesn't know what she's talking about
taxes and workers shouldn't be in the
same sentence I don't even think she
knows what wokeness is this is the issue
she's going to be furious when she finds
out which party has been in power in
Britain for the last 13 years all those
problems and yeah she was one of the
five Prime Ministers during that period
I mean it is it would be it would be
funny if it wasn't also quite serious I
wish someone put a head of lettuce next
because when when I was talking to the
producers earlier I said Liz truss is
the reason I can't get a mortgage I was
going to get one and the next day I
called off the talks of the mortgage
advisors because her and quasiquarters
and crashed the economy I know someone
as well in the same position I actually
know multiple people oh God she should
be on uh Kia Storm's Christmas card list
well she did far more for labor in the
opposition than she ever did in 44 days
it's incredible look so it seems like
The Comeback tour hasn't won over many
fans here now uh moving on this show
we've been talking about the theme of
britishness anti-british nurses dispute
about whether Biden was anti-british a
couple of stories today about the theme
of um pride and respect and uh
embarrassment to be honest I'm
embarrassed by this story that's been in
the papers for a few days now about this
Pub in Essex um which in which the
landlady displayed gollywood dolls
um reading about it reading the
responses to it I mean seeing the police
response I assume the viewers are quite
familiar with this now the Essex police
sent out I think it was around five
police just to bag up the dolls the
police not doing themselves any favor in
this because of course people are going
to criticize their response to this but
ultimately I'm most embarrassed that
we're talking about this in 2023 and
whether or not it is racist of course it
is racist in my mind I'm more
embarrassed by Sue Ella breatherman's
response thank you uh and I I don't know
I don't know if this woman has any media
training but I think when someone puts
up clearly racist uh
objects in plain view of the public your
first reaction shouldn't be that police
should have better things to do yes okay
it's not ideal for them to be handling
this but you have to first acknowledge
it is racist it's like having Nazi
memorabilia in public right it's not
illegal but it's extremely distasteful
and the fact that as a Home Secretary
she didn't recognize she didn't speak
about it I just I I shouldn't be
embarrassed every time one of the you
know the foremost members of the cabinet
opens her mouth she does a deliberately
the Home Secretary she's she's stirring
up uh racism for hate ridden Division
and hopes to divide
I can't believe that now but they're
clean right they're clearly racist now I
can accept some people will not
recognize that or fully appreciate it
but you know the racism is in the name
of but this Pub those who think
these are just heroic people one the
landlord was pictured in a Britain first
t-shirt Britain first is an extremist
often uh racist and violent group his
wife the landlady just as I was just
convenient for him to put it on secondly
they were pictured and they post it on
Facebook hanging those dolls in the past
saying this is what used to happen in
Mississippi where of course black people
Village put it all together put it all
together and do not think this is a
heroic because it is and don't think it
is part of this debate about what is
woke and oh we can't accept it we must
we write history I understand the
commenters the people that have viewed
the story and said but we had these on
jam jars when we were children and you
know it was part of History find facts
that did happen but we've moved on
decades and we're a better country for
it I quite agree now um and just to
Esther's point about the Home Secretary
sources told Sky News as a waste of
police resources quote the home
secretary's views have now been made
very plain to Essex police so they're
under no Illusions police forces should
not be getting involved in this kind of
nonsense so as Esther pointed out
they're putting all the onus on the
police response they're not actually
talking about the issue at hand Essex
police in response saying this uh
denying the Home Secretary had contacted
them directly over the incident saying
we maintain operational independence
from the home office which ensures that
every investigation is carried out
without fear or favor let's move on to
something a little bit more cheerful
sort of but about being embarrassed to
be English again now this story caught
my attention yesterday Keith McNally he
is a restaurateur in New York he runs
this fancy restaurant called Bautista
that all celebs love to go to he wrote
an Instagram post in which he put sort
of the Union Jack and he said I'm
ashamed to be English Keith McNally was
born in London he says I wonder why
English people are generally the worst
tippers in New York restaurants
especially if they're middle or upper
class this is not a complaint it's just
a fact in fact even the Scots generally
hit better than English in New York
restaurants what did you both make of
the story Kevin just remember though
does he know that tipping is meant to be
voluntary yeah I mean I feel like that
got lost why doesn't he pay his staff a
decent wage so they don't have to rely
on tipping notice he used a Scottish
stereotype about that somehow stingy but
look I I've never quite understood and I
do tip normally in a restaurant give
tips about I always wonder why if I'm
just getting my meal served nicely why
do I think that's like exceptional
service and I'm tipping I don't tip a
police officer if they help me
yeah or a bus driver yeah well so on
this theme of embarrassment Bridges well
I'm not embarrassed to be British
actually because as you said Kevin uh 10
seems to be the norm I would tip 10 in a
in a restaurant anywhere here in the UK
and I tend to take that with me when I
visit the us although I am aware I'm
keenly aware and I'm paying that bill up
in New York uh on the few times I've
been there it's just not enough because
there's a different expectation in the
US the system is much more that we
substitute their wages 15 to 25 I think
it shouldn't have obscene what why don't
they just raise their prices so they can
pay their stock living wages as opposed
to expecting me to to Fork out at 20
extra like I mean they might as well
just put that on the bill that McNally
put his hand in his own pocket instead
of expected everybody else to subsidize
his Law wages yeah uh will you both be
eating in Balthazar next time you go to
New York
that goes to show you the power of an
Instagram post the power of some press
as well been talking about it throughout
the show today what it means to be
British what it means to be anti-british
pretty proud to be British given some of
the debate we've had on the show this
evening voices from all sides that is it
from me this evening from Esther and
Kevin in the studio as well whatever
you're up to make sure it's uncensored
good night
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage and you're
stretching it you can say whatever
gender you are for your sex your male or
your female all right JJ plus he become
fabulous
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apology
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it